hello everyone someone in the comment
section asked me if I would show up or
Cara's game and since I haven't shown
any for Cara's games yet I decided to
show you one of my favorite games my
ball carries this game he's playing
against rule of Spielman and the style
of Rudolph Spielman kind of resembled
the style of Michael Tao this game was
played in 1938 in Netherlands and well
it kind of shows you how to play against
a player who is over aggressive and you
will see even though he was only 22
years old
Bob Harris is quite a positional player
and and the natural counter attacker so
little Spielman is white and Polaris is
black so we have e for by Spielman and
can replace a six
we have d4 d5 the French defense nice
III Knight to f6 we have E 5 9 f to be
7f 4 C 5 D captors on c5 Knight to c6 a3
preparing to put b4 to really fix that
pawn on c5 but Paris captures its uncie
5 and in this position as Pillman jumps
into the attack with Queen to g4 so it
would be kind of risky to castle here so
Karis plays g6 first this kind of does
weak in the dark squares but it's it's a
necessary move so we have Knight to f3
by Spielman and we have a six by
carriers so Bishop to d3 d5 Karis is
preparing to push before but still
non-stop sets he plays before himself so
we have Bishop to a7 we have a 4 by
Spillman h5 attacking the Queen Queen to
g3 Queen to e7 and in this position and
this is kind of a critical position of
the game stealing plays f5 he plays a
towel move although in those days it was
called a Spielman move and well what the
Spielman want here well obviously the
pawn sacrifice so if for example D
captures an f5 then this if he captures
on f5 then this D pawn is weakened this
is good for white but spilling had in
mind something like G captures on f5 and
after Bishop captures on f5 e casters on
f5 Knight captures on d5 attack
in this queen so the Pinkerton got
really to e6 because of this 937 check
walking the king and queen so he would
have to play Queen to d8 and here a
Spielman had this the Queen to g7 idea
in mind so only move would be rook to f8
and now Bishop to g5 attacking the Queen
the Queen has nowhere to go so after f6
and Queen to g6 check this rook would
have to block and this e six move would
be winning
so after f5 a root of spillin really did
spend a lot of time and he worked out
the tactics and to tell you something
well actually this G captures an f5 move
is the strongest move recommended by the
engine and I will let you tell me why in
the comments if anybody is interested in
finding out but Karis finds a human move
to refute this f5 idea and it's a very
strong positional idea it's a well a
very silent move with a deadly one Karis
plays Bishop to b8 and what this move
Bishop to v8 he is attacking this e five
point three times and well let's see how
Spielman deals with it
he plays F captures on g6 and here Karis
plays Knight D captures on e5 and
already you can see that carat is
threatening to capture this d3 Bishop
and open that discovery to the Queen
from the bishop on b8 so still in place
G captures on f7 woods check we have
Queen captures on f7 and we have Knight
to g5 attacking blacks Queen so here
Karis has to defend the Queen and he
plays Queen to f6 and this is an
extremely strong group you can see that
after this Knight moves well the Queen
will be attacking this knight on c3 and
also the rook on a one so this is a very
strong strong diagonal for the Queen to
be on but the rule of Spillman like I
said it was a very aggressive player and
he tries to continue this a few plays
rook to f1 and well now it has to find a
move for carriers there are a lot of
moves and well probably nice casters and
e3 is an idea but this would be wrong
cameras finds the Neva bedroom
Karis plates that are nice to g4 and in
this position well there's really
nothing white can play if the point is
captured or for example if the queen is
captured then simply Kara's would
capture white queen would check and
after H captures and g3 simply pick up
the rook he is at the exchange and well
this is this is winning so after Knight
to g4 by Karis Spillman fries Queen to
f3 trying to exchange Queens like this
but this this is leaving this c3 Knight
undefended so Kara just captures that
would check win captures and c3 would
check we have Kings to d1 and here
Spillman is offering a whole rook on a1
and well if you ask an engine capturing
the rook on a1 is probably the strongest
move but Karis does not capture the rook
on a1 Karis plays Queen to g7 he says I
don't need a rock to win this game
already have a piece and well I think
Queen to g7 is winning and he is quite
right we have 22 by riddle Spearman and
I wrote the f8 offering to exchange
ropes by Karis human captors and f8 King
casters on f8 and now nice captures any
6-foot check so we have Bishop captures
on e6 Queen captures an e6 and here
Karis again she doesn't capture the rook
because he does not want to allow human
any country play whatsoever so he plays
nice to F to check and well this is
finishing the game instantly because the
well white King can only go to e1 if he
goes to e 2 then this night to d4 check
oh [ __ ] the king and queen and if he
goes to d2 well then this Bishop to f4
check will be very deadly it will
develop a piece for free and it will
exchange every piece so all we move is
into e1 and now Karis can exchange this
Bishop with check so Knight captures and
III would check we have C captures and
d3 and in this position well rule of
film and resigned
because well Karis doesn't even have to
pick up this rook and if this game
continued she probably even wouldn't
pick up this rock she was probably just
play Queen to e7 exchange Queens and win
the game with a pot with a piece up so
this is one of my favorite games because
it really shows well since I love
attacking players and I love players
like me Hotel and real Spielman also and
well everyone who can win a game with a
fancy combination but that's the thing
with ball carriers you simply can't
attack pork errors even the strong
candidates tournament that Michael Tao
one I think it was in Zurich in 1959 he
beat everyone with a fantastic score
except Paul Karras he had he had a
negative score against poker is because
few style of play simply didn't work on
Paul Karras so yeah that's why that's
why poker is usually beat every attacker
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed this game by for Karis the
Estonian powerhouse and it usually can
check - in my previous videos here and
that's about it
I'll see you soon